we humans have known for thousands of
years just looking at our environment
around us that there are different
substances and these different
substances tend to have different
properties and not only do they have
different properties one might reflect
light in a certain way or not reflect
light or be a certain color or be have a
certain at a certain temperature be
liquid or gas or be a solid but we also
start to observe how they react with
each other in certain circumstances and
here's pictures of some of these
substances this right here is carbon and
this is in the in its graphite form this
right here is lead this right here is
gold and all of the ones that i've drawn
that i've shown pictures of here and i
got them all from this website right
over there
all of these are in their solid form but
we also know that we it looks like
there's certain types of air and you
know certain types of air particles and
depending on what type of air particles
you're looking at whether it is carbon
or oxygen or nitrogen that seems to have
different types of properties or there's
other things that can be liquid or even
if you raise the temperature high enough
on these things you could if you raise a
high temperature high enough on gold or
lead you could get a liquid or if you if
you kind of if you if you burn this
carbon you can get it to a gaseous state
you can release it into the atmosphere
you can break its structure so these are
things that we've all kind of that
humanity has observed for thousands of
years but it leads to a natural question
that would used to be a philosophical
question but now we can answer it a
little bit better and that question is
is if you keep breaking down this carbon
into smaller and smaller chunks is there
some smallest chunk some smallest unit
of this stuff of the substance that
still has the properties of carbon and
if you were to somehow you break that
down even further somehow you would lose
the properties of the carbon
and the answer is there is
and so just to get our terminology we
call these different substances that
these pure substances that have these
specific properties at certain
temperatures and react in certain ways
we call them elements
we call them elements carbon is an
element lead is an element gold is an
element you might say that water is an
element and in in history people have
referred to water as an element but now
we know that water is made up of more
basic elements it's made of oxygen and
of hydrogen and all of our elements
and all of our elements are listed here
in the periodic table of elements c
stands for carbon i'm just going through
the ones that are very relevant to
humanity but over time you'll probably
familiarize yourself with all of these
this is oxygen this is nitrogen this is
silicon this is a you is gold this is
lead and that most basic unit of any of
these elements is an is the atom is the
atom
so if you were to if you were to keep
digging in and keep taking smaller and
smaller chunks of this eventually you
would get to a carbon atom do the same
thing over here eventually you would get
to a gold atom you did the same thing
over here eventually you'd get some this
little small for lack of a better word
particle that you would call a lead atom
and you wouldn't be able to break that
down anymore and still call that lead
for it to still have the properties of
lead and just to give you an idea this
is really something that i have trouble
imagining
is that atoms are unbelievably small
really unimaginably small so for example
carbon my hair is also made out of
carbon in fact most of me is made out of
carbon most of mo in fact most of all
living things are made out of carbon and
so if you took my hair and so my hair is
carbon
my hair is mostly carbon so if you took
my hair right over here and my hair
isn't yellow but it contrasts nicely
with the black my hair is black but if i
did that you wouldn't be able to see it
on the screen but if you took my hair
here and i were to ask you how many
carbon atoms wide is my hair what is the
dye so if you took a cross section of my
hair not the length the the width of my
hair and said how many carbon atoms wide
is that
and you might guess oh you know i salary
told me it's a it's a they're very small
so maybe there's a thousand carbon atoms
there are ten thousand or a hundred
thousand i would say no
there are one million carbon atoms or
you could string one million carbon
atoms across the width of the average
human hair and that's obviously an
approximation it's not exactly one
million but that gives you a sense of
how small an atom is you'll pluck a hair
out of your head and just imagine
putting a million things next to each
other across across the hair not the
width not the length of the hair the
width of the hair it's even hard to see
the width of hair and there would be a
million carbon atoms just going along it
now it would be pretty cool in in and of
itself
that we've
we we do know that there is this most
basic building block of carbon this most
basic building block of any element but
what's even neater is that those basic
building blocks are related to each
other that they're that eat a carbon
atom is made up of even more fundamental
particles a gold a gold atom is made up
of even more fundamental part
fundamental particles and depending and
they're actually defined by
the arrangement of those fundamental
particles and if you were to change the
number of fundamental particles you have
you could change the properties of the
element how it would react or you could
even change the element itself and just
to understand it a little bit better
let's talk about those fundamental
elements
so you have the proton
you have the proton and the proton is
actually the defining the number of
protons in the nucleus of an atom and
i'll talk about the nucleus in a second
that is what defines the element so this
is what defines an element
when you look at the periodic table
right here they're actually written in
order of atomic number and the atomic
number is literally just the number of
protons in the element so by definition
hydrogen has one proton helium has two
protons carbon has six protons you
cannot have carbon with seven protons if
you did it would be nitrogen it would
not be carbon anymore oxygen has eight
protons if somehow you add another
proton to there it wouldn't be oxygen
anymore it would be fluorine so it
defines the element it defines the
element and the atomic number
the number of protons number of protons
and remember that's the number that's
written right at the top here for each
of these elements in the periodic table
the number of protons is equal to the
atomic number
is equal to the atomic number it's a su
and they put that number up here because
that is the defining characteristic of
an element
the other two constituents of an of an
atom i guess we could call it that way
are the electron
are the electron and the neutron
and
the neutron
and the model you can start to build in
your head and this model as we'll as we
go through chemistry we'll see can it'll
get a little bit more abstract and
really hard to conceptualize but one way
to think about it is you have the
protons and the neutrons that are at the
center of the atom they're the nucleus
of the atom so for example carbon we
know has six protons so one two three
four five six
nor carbon 12 which is a version of
carbon will also have six neutrons you
can have versions of carbon that have a
different number of neutrons so the
neutrons can change the electrons can
change you can still have the same
element the protons can't change if you
change the protons you got a different
element
so let me draw a carbon 12 nucleus so 1
2 3 4 5
6. so this right here is the nucleus of
carbon
12 and sometimes it'll be written like
this
and sometimes they'll actually write the
number of protons as well and the reason
why we write it carbon-12 you know i
counted out i counted out six neutrons
is that this is the total you could view
this as the total number of one way to
view it and we'll get a little bit
nuanced in the future is that this is
the total number of protons and neutrons
inside of its nucleus and this carbon by
definition has an atomic number of six
but we can rewrite it here just so that
we can remind ourselves so at the center
of a carbon atom we have this nucleus
and carbon 12 will have six protons and
six neutrons another version of carbon
carbon 14 will still have six protons
but then it would have
eight neutrons so the number of neutrons
can change but this is carbon-12 right
over here
and if carbon-12 is neutral and i'll
i'll i'll give a little nuance on this
word in a second as well if it is
neutral it'll also have six electrons so
let me draw those six electrons one two
three four five six and one way and this
is maybe the first order way of thinking
about the relations uh the relationship
between the electrons and the nucleus is
that you can imagine the electrons are
kind of moving around buzzing around
this nucleus one model is you could kind
of thinking of them as orbiting around
the nucleus but that's not quite right
they don't orbit the way that a planet
say orbits around the sun but that is a
that's a good starting point another way
is kind of they're kind of jumping
around the nucleus or they're buzzing
around the nucleus
and that's just because reality just
gets very strange at this level and will
actually have to go into quantum physics
to really understand what the electron
is doing but a first mental model in
your head is at the center of this atom
of this carbon-12 atom you have this
nucleus you have this nucleus right over
there and these electrons are jumping
around
this nucleus and the reason why these
electrons don't just go off away from
this nucleus why they're kind of bound
to this nucleus and they form part of
this atom is that protons have a
positive charge
have a positive charge and electrons
have a negative charge and it's one of
these part it's one of these
properties of these fundamental
particles when you start thinking about
well what is a charge fundamentally
other than a label and it starts to get
kind of deep but the one thing that we
know when we talk about electromagnetic
force is that unlike charges attract
each other so the best way to think
about it is protons and electrons
because they have different charges they
attract each other neutrons are neutral
so they're really they're really just
sitting here inside of the nucleus and
they do affect the properties
on some level of some of these for for
some at for some atoms of certain
elements but the reason why we have the
electrons not just flying off on their
own is because they are they are
attracted they are attracted towards
towards the nucleus and they also have
an unbelievably high velocity
it's actually hard for
and we start touching once again on on a
very uh strange part of physics once we
start talking about what an electron
actually is doing but it has enough it
it i guess you could say it's jumping
around enough that it doesn't want to
just
fall into the nucleus i guess is one way
of thinking about it
and so
and so i mentioned
carbon 12 right over here defined by the
number of protons oxygen would be not
defined by having eight protons but once
again electrons can interact with other
electrons or they can be taken away by
other atoms and that actually is forms a
lot of our understanding of chemistry is
based on how many electrons an atom has
or a certain element has and how those
electrons are configured and how and how
this and and how the electrons of other
elements are configured or maybe other
other atoms of that same element we can
start we can start to predict how
an atom of one element can react with
another atom of that same element or an
atom of one element could begin how it
could react or how it could bond or not
bond or be attracted to a repel another
atom of another element so for example
and we'll learn a lot more about this in
the future is it is possible for another
another atom someplace that to swipe
away an electron from a carbon just
because for whatever reason it's it's
and we'll talk about certain elements
certain
neutral
atoms of certain elements have a a
larger affinity for electrons than
others so one may be one of those swipes
an electron away from a carbon and then
this carbon will be having less
electrons than protons so they would
have five electrons and six protons and
then it would have a net positive charge
so in this carbon-12 the first version i
did i had six protons six electrons the
charges canceled out if i lose an
electron then i only have five of these
and then i would have a net positive
charge and we're going to talk a lot
more about all of this throughout the
chemistry playlist but hopefully you
have an appreciation that this is
already starting to get really cool once
we can hardly we can already get to this
really fundamental
this fundamental
building block called the atom and
what's even neater is that this
fundamental building block is built of
is built of even more fundamental
building blocks and these things can all
be swapped around to change the
properties of an atom or to even go from
an atom of one element to an atom of
another element